-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, today is Thursday,
and the star of "Wednesday,"
Jenna Ortega is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can see her new movie,
"Scream VI," on Friday.
And this weekend, she's hosting
"Saturday Night Live,"
which runs into Sunday.
Right now, Monday is like,
"Did I do something?"
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news here.
Former president Trump is
releasing a book called "Letters
to Trump" that's made up of
150 private letters sent to him
by big-name celebrities
like Oprah, the Clintons,
and Liza Minnelli.
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of strange.
Trump is bragging like,
"Look at all the friends
I used to have."
[ Laughter ]
"It's all in the book."
Yep, the first five letters are
from celebrities,
the rest are just fan mail from
Scott Baio.
[ Laughter ]
If the book does well,
the next volume will be
a collection of
his favorite subpoenas.
[ Laughter ]
"This is a good one.
This is a great one.
I love that."
Here's the cover of the new
book. Look at the cover. Yeah.
"Letters to Trump."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
That's a picture of Trump
writing a letter to himself.
It's letters "to" --
Ah, forget it.
I would like to see the letters
that Trump wrote.
It's like, "My dearest
Colonel Sanders,
I can't wait to meet you."
[ Laughter ]
"Meeting you would be the top
thing on my bucket list.
L-O-L.
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears, this year the
Oscars is actually going up
against the season finale of
"The Last of Us."
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah, the Oscars producers must
be worried about ratings because
this is the promo they just
released. Look at this.
-This Sunday, the stars come out
for the 95th Oscars.
And if you're thinking of
watching "The Last of Us"
to find out what happens
on the season finale,
well, you don't have to.
Joel dies.
[ Laughter ]
The Oscars, where the magic
happens.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-No reason to watch.
-Don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
Watch the Oscars.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
The WWE is in talks with
multiple states about legalizing
betting on scripted matches.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, betting on scripted
matches.
What could possibly go right?
[ Laughter ]
If you're going to bet on
a sport that's scripted,
bet on boxing.
[ Audience oohs ]
Hey. Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-You guys said it.
I didn't say it.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, listen to this, Spotify
just announced
that it is focusing on
video podcasts.
Yep. Video podcasts.
And there's some pretty
interesting ads. Check this out.
-We all love podcasts, but now,
imagine if that podcast
interview was on television with
lights and hair and makeup
and music and a desk
and a chair and a host.
-♪ Hey, hey-hey ♪
-"The Tonight Show,"
a podcast you can see.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait, we're doing it?
That's what we're doing.
It's a podcast you can see! Yes!
Well, this is crazy.
NASA is warning that an asteroid
could hit Earth on
Valentine's Day in 2046.
[ Man cheers ]
No.
[ Laughter ]
No. No, I don't --
I don't want to --
-What is going on?
-Terrible news.
[ Laughter ]
That is actually terrible news.
Not a "whoo!" It's a "ooh."
-It's gonna hit Earth, yay!
-But believe it or not, Hallmark
is already selling special
Valentine's Day cards
for the big day.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, check these out.
The first card says...
You open it up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
This next card says...
You open it up, it says...
The next card says...
Open it up, it says...
And finally, this last card
says...
Open it up, it says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sweet. Really nice.
Hey, I read that the TSA is
ordering airports to step up
their cybersecurity.
Airports are like, "Yeah, we'll
get on that right after
we figure out shoes and belts.
Take 'em off. I don't know
what's in --"
[ Laughter ]
"We don't -- I don't know
anything about belts.
Take 'em off.
Look at that guy's feet.
That looks suspicious."
You shouldn't be smoking here.
Meanwhile, JFK Airport is like,
"We have no Wi-Fi, computers,
or electricity.
How much more secure
can we get?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
We don't have anything.
Speaking of travel, a woman said
that Delta Airlines damaged
her bag during a flight
and agreed to replace it
but then sent her
13 new suitcases.
Well, new to her.
They were just 13 suitcases of
other passengers.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is going viral.
Maine is trying to get rid of
any inappropriate
license plates. Yeah.
But one driver claims that his
plate is being misinterpreted.
Watch this.
-A vegan in Maine whose custom
license plate contains the word
"tofu," is one of the drivers
caught up in the state crackdown
on vulgar vanity plates.
This is the plate in question.
It says "luvtofu," but the state
thinks it could be seen as
an inappropriate reference.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That person is definitely
not vegan, and that 100% means
what officials think it means,
okay?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, you know, we love
video games here
at "The Tonight Show" and
we also love movies.
That's why we're so excited
about
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie"
coming out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
In honor of that, the Roots and
I got together with the cast of
the movie, along with some
special guests, and performed
our version of "The Super Mario
Bros." theme song.
Check it out.
[ Scatting "Super Mario Bros.
Overworld Theme" ]
♪♪
[ Scatting "Super Mario Bros.
Underground Theme" ]
[ Pipe warp sound ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Scatting "Super Mario Bros.
Underground Theme" ]
♪♪
-[ Scatting "Super Mario Bros.
Overworld Theme" ]
Underground Theme" ]
♪♪
[ Bricks crash, power-up sound ]
[ Scatting tempo quickens ]
[ 1-Up sound ]
♪♪
-♪ Ba-da-ba, ba-da, ba ♪
♪ Buhhhh ♪
[ All harmonizing
various themes ]
-♪ Baow! ♪
-[ Mario Death sound ]
-[ Scatting Mario Death sound ]